un mecanismo es la secuencia de pasos
elementales por la que se desarrolla una
reacción si analizamos esta reacción
aquí tenemos dióxido de nitrógeno más
monóxido de carbono que nos da óxido de
nitrógeno y dióxido de carbono nuestros
reactivos no se transforman en productos
en un solo paso en realidad hay un
mecanismo para que la reacción se
desarrolle este es un posible mecanismo
que tiene dos pasos elementales en el
primer paso observen que tenemos no2 más
n otros para obtener n o más
n o tres y en el segundo paso el n o
tres que acabamos de obtener reacciona
con seo para producir n otros más co2
cualquier mecanismo debe de tener pasos
elementales y si juntamos estos dos
pasos obtendremos la reacción general
damos todos los reactivos de un lado nos
queda n otros
n otros más n o tres más c
y luego pongamos todos los productos de
un lado
aquí tenemos n o más n o tres más
n o dos más autos
ahora analicemos los dos lados y veamos
que podemos cancelar aquí tenemos un no2
que se cancela con este no2 de la
derecha también tenemos un n o tres que
se cancela con este veamos que nos ha
quedado del lado izquierdo nos quedamos
con n o dos más
o así que nos quedó dióxido de nitrógeno
más monóxido de carbono y del lado de
los productos nos quedó óxido de
nitrógeno no2 sido de carbono co2
entonces al juntar los vasos elementales
1 y 2 del mecanismo obtuvimos esta
reacción general que es la misma que
tenemos aquí arriba así que este es un
posible mecanismo para esta reacción
ahora observen que aquí tenemos este no3
que obtuvimos en el primer paso y
observen que en el segundo paso el n o 3
se consume a esto se le llama
intermediario
este es un intermediario significa que
se produce en un paso y se consume en
otro paso del mecanismo un intermediario
no es un reactivo ni tampoco un producto
simplemente es algo que aparece durante
la reacción y que si logramos detectarlo
nos ayuda a entender mejor cómo ocurre
el mecanismo un posible mecanismo
también debe coincidir con la ley de
velocidad experimental de la reacción
general nuestra reacción general es 1
no2 +
no sé a qué nos da 1 n
1 0 2 y la ley de velocidad obtenida
experimentalmente para esta reacción es
velocidad de reacción es igual a la
constante de velocidad k por la
concentración de no2 al cuadrado así que
la reacción este segundo orden respecto
al dióxido de nitrógeno se observa en la
reacción general balanceada aquí tenemos
el dióxido de nitrógeno pero tiene un
coeficiente de 1 así que no podemos
tomar el coeficiente y convertirlo en el
exponente porque experimentalmente se
determinó que el exponente es 2 entonces
solo podemos usar el coeficiente como
exponente
cuando hablamos de reacciones
elementales por otro lado esta reacción
este orden cero respecto al monóxido de
carbono por eso no aparece en la ley de
velocidad
entonces análisis
tenemos el mecanismo y tratemos de
explicar la ley de velocidad que se
obtuvo experimentalmente en el primer
paso del mecanismo se forma el
intermediario no3 y este es el paso
lento del mecanismo en el segundo paso
el intermediario no3 reacciona para
formar otros productos y este es el paso
rápido del mecanismo así que el paso
lento se le conoce como el paso
determinante de la velocidad de reacción
el paso 1 de este mecanismo es el paso
determinante de la velocidad por ejemplo
digamos que el paso 1 se tarda un
segundo es decir se necesita de un
segundo para formar el intermediario y
supongamos que el segundo paso al ser
más rápido solo necesita 1 x 10 a la
menos 8 segundos entonces cuál es el
tiempo total de la reacción
simplemente sumamos 1 más 1 por 10 a la
menos 8 que es igual a aproximadamente
un segundo así que el paso más lento
determina el tiempo de reacción porque
en este caso el paso lento tarda un
segundo y eso es aproximadamente lo que
tarda toda la reacción así que al tratar
de encontrar la velocidad de toda la
reacción esto es igual a la velocidad
del paso determinante y podemos saber la
velocidad de ese paso determinante
porque el paso 1 es una reacción
elemental así que podemos aplicar lo que
vimos en vídeos anteriores la velocidad
es igual a la constante de velocidad que
para el paso 1 es k 1 k subíndice 1
la concentración de nuestros reactivos
que en este caso tenemos no2 y como
tiene un coeficiente de 1 recuerden que
para una reacción elemental podemos usar
el coeficiente como exponente así que
nos queda a la primera potencia por la
concentración de otro no2 no2 y como
también tiene un coeficiente de 1
entonces nos queda 1 de exponente esta
es la ley de velocidad para el paso
determinante de la reacción y si la
factory zamo se nos queda que la
velocidad es igual a la constante k 1
por la concentración de no2 al cuadrado
observen que esta es la misma ley de
velocidad que se determinó
experimentalmente así que este mecanismo
si coincide con la ley de velocidad de
experimental
es nuestra reacción general este segundo
orden respecto al dióxido de nitrógeno y
de orden cero respecto al monóxido de
carbono observen que el monóxido de
carbono aparece hasta el segundo paso no
en el paso determinante por eso es de
orden cero no se toma en cuenta también
observen que esta constante cada uno
debe ser igual a la constante k de la
reacción general